THE STATE OF THE PIXEL:
As a customer, what do you want out
of a smartphone? Affordability? Reliability?
Strong performance? Customizability? Well,
one could argue that the Google Pixel is exactly
that. Google prices their Pixel phones very
competitively for the western market starting
at just $350 while offering near flagship level
performance. Pixels also get strong reviews
both from users and tech journalists. And
Pixels aren’t some sort of sketchy knockoff
that you buy from Alibaba either. Pixels come
from one of the largest and most reputable
companies in the world: Google. I mean,
even if you don’t especially like Google, it
might make sense to get a Pixel and enjoy a
strong smartphone experience on Google’s dime.
As such, you would think that this is the type of
product that would explode in popularity. Google
is solving all of the issues that people generally
complain about when it comes to smartphones and
giving customers exactly what they’re asking for.
And to be fair, the Pixel is performing quite
well within a niche portion of the population,
but it's very much just a niche portion
of the population. Globally speaking,
Google doesn’t even control 1% of the market
despite having basically infinite resources,
being around since the beginning of smartphones,
and controlling Android. That’s often pointed to
as one of Apple’s largest advantages. They’re
able to control both the software and hardware
to create the best experience possible. But, can’t
Google do the exact same thing with the Pixel? I’m
picking on Google here, but I’m not talking
about Google really at all. They’re just the
most notable example. You probably know a bunch
of other smartphone models that are even more
value packed. Maybe it’s from Xiaomi or Samsung
or Huawei or even the iPhone SE. But regardless
of which value packed smartphone you’re talking
about, they all suffer from the same problem:
no one buys them. So, here’s why the Google
Pixel is having such a tough time becoming
a big player and why you should think twice
before giving customers exactly what they want.
SKEPTICAL CUSTOMERS:
Taking a look back, Google’s
foray with smartphones date all the way back to
the beginning of smartphones in 2009. This year,
Google would launch their first ever smartphone:
the Android Dev Phone 1 for $400. They didn’t
market this phone very much because as the
name suggested it wasn’t made for consumers,
it was made for developers. It didn’t take much
longer for Google to launch a consumer oriented
phone though. In 2010, they would come out with
the Nexus One but this itself would turn out to be
a massive flop. Why you ask? Well, largely because
Google was going against the grain. Instead of
locking in contracts with all of the big national
carriers, Google decided to sell the Nexus One
directly to consumers for $530. Nowadays, this
is pretty much standard practice. Everyone knows
about retail pricing and contracting pricing
for smartphones. But, back in the late 2000s
and early 2010s, there was only one pricing
model that the average person was familiar with:
the contract pricing model as this was the only
way to buy iPhones at least within the US. You
would usually pay $100 or $200 upfront for the
phone and sign a 2 year contract with AT&T,
Verizon, or Sprint. From there, you would pay a
set amount every month for 2 years until you paid
off the full cost of the smartphone. The reason
Apple did this was to mask the true price of
iPhones and make the price a lot more digestible
for a market that was seeing smartphones for the
first time. It wasn’t till mid 2011 that Apple
started selling unlocked iPhones for retail price
on their website. And it really wasn’t till the
late 2010s and until T Mobile popularized unlocked
smartphones that the average person became aware
of the difference between contract pricing and
retail pricing. Until then, as far as the average
person knew, the price of an iPhone was $200.
That’s what they would have to pay upfront and
that’s what they saw everywhere. At stores, on TV,
on magazines, on ads, everywhere. So, when Google
came in with an unlocked phone in 2009 for $530,
the general public was naturally put off by the
seemingly high price. Google’s position within
the overall market has changed over the years,
but they’re still very much going against the
grain. While everyone is selling phones for $800
or a $1000, Google is trying to sell phones for
500 bucks, 600 bucks, but it’s the same underlying
issue. By giving customers exactly what they want,
you’re always gonna be going against the industry
at large which naturally earns you a lot of
skepticism. And thing is, the hardest people to
sell to are not people who don’t want your product
but the people who don’t trust your product. If
you try to convince these people based on facts,
they’ll only be put off more. They’ll start
wondering: if your product is truly this awesome,
what’s in it for you? Whats the catch? And that’s
exactly what’s happening with the Google Pixel.
Over the years, Google has built up a reputation
as someone who does shady stuff to make money like
collecting data and intruding privacy. So, when
Google comes out with a smartphone that seems too
good to be true, people immediately wonder why.
And they’re not wrong for wondering why. I mean,
it’s not like Google is handing out Pixels
at 0 margin as a philanthropic effort. No,
they’re handing them out at 0 margin because
they’re ok with sacrificing profit to gain
market share and they know that they can monetize
your use of the Pixel using Google services. So,
they do indeed have ulterior motives. And the
problem is that when you go against the grain
and give customers exactly what they want, these
ulterior movies become more visible then ever. So,
Google is constantly having to fight this uphill
battle against consumer skepticism. But that only
tells half the story because even consumers
who aren’t skeptical don’t want the Pixel.
ASPIRATIONAL PURCHASE:
From the very beginning, the smartphone
industry has been somewhat of an aspirational
category. Half of this is because of marketing
and how smartphones have been positioned over the
years. Apple for example has simply leaned more
and more into premium branding especially with
the pro series. Realistically speaking, Apple
knows that the average person won't spring for the
pro series. That’s why 80% of their lineup is not
the pro series. With that being said though, the
pro series is actually extremely important for
the rest of Apple’s lineup because it provides
context. It establishes Apple as someone who
puts out top tier pro level phones. And while you
may not be able to purchase the pro series today,
it gives you something to aspire to. This is a
very common marketing technique used across a
wide range of industries. It’s the same reason
why Costco puts a bunch of super expensive TVs
right at the entrance. It asserts that that’s what
the most successful Costco shoppers are buying.
And by having a Costco membership, you too are
part of that “elite” group of shoppers. It’s the
same thing with the American Express black card
as well. Most of these items are something that
the average person will realistically never get,
but the presence of these items are what make all
the difference. So, that’s the marketing side of
things. The other half of the story is simply how
smartphones fit into our lifestyles. The average
person spends over 3 hours on their smartphones
everyday, and if you’re on the younger side of
things, the number is likely even higher. As such,
people don’t view buying smartphones the same
way as buying trash bags or paper towels or
some other household item. With these items, most
people do just get the cheapest option with decent
reliability. With smartphones, however, people
see it as more of an investment. They’re gonna
end up spending 1000s of hours on this device,
so they’re much more willing to spend the extra
$100 or $200 and get the better phone even if they
don’t need it. And this only makes it even harder
for Google to sell the Pixel. Even if they’re able
to overcome the skepticism surrounding the Pixel,
consumers still just don’t want it. It’s more
than likely that the average consumer would say
something along the lines of: It’s great that
Google is offering a well priced competitive
option, but for myself, I like getting something
a bit more high end. And when they say high end,
they usually just mean getting an iPhone for the
same price. Hearing this, you might be saying
that Google just needs to advertise more. If they
just put the Pixel infront of people more often,
people will finally get it right? Well, the truth
is that Google has already already been spending
hundreds of millions on marketing. Now to be
fair, that is 4-5 times less than Apple and
Samsung historically, but here’s the deal,
Google’s market share is not 4-5 times less
than Apple and Samsung. It’s more like 30-40 times
less. Aka, despite being the king of digital ads,
Google’s return on advertising spend is garbage in
comparison to Apple and Samsung. Now, this could
be partially due to the the marketing campaign’s
themselves. Maybe, Google’s campaigns just aren’t
as good. But, I suspect that this has more to do
with all of the intangible factors that we’ve been
discussing. Apple and Samsung’s flagship phones
simply strike a chord with consumers that Google’s
budget phones do not because smartphones are often
an aspirational guilty pleasure type of purchase,
not something that’s strictly objective or
logical. And that brings us into real takeaway
of all of this which is that consumers
often simply don’t know what they want.
CUSTOMERS DON’T KNOW:
We often hear the business
mantra that the customer is always right, and
in some industries like hospitality and tourism,
that’s a great slogan to live by. Even if the
customer is technically wrong, it’s better to
assume that they’re right to keep them happy. This
mantra doesn’t work as well within the tech or
really any innovation driven industry because the
truth is: customers have no clue what they really
want. Henry Ford has this famous quote that
if he had asked customers what they wanted,
they would’ve said faster horses. Steve Jobs
very much took this quote to heart as he
strongly believed that “People don't know
what they want until you show it to them.
That's why I never rely on market research. Our
task is to read things that are not yet on the
page.” And this sort of mindset is what led to
many of Apple’s best innovations. For example,
choosing to not use a stylus. Using intuitive
methods to zoom in and out by pinching the screen
instead of pressing a plus or minus button. Face
ID instead of Touch ID, and so on. Oftentimes,
Apple’s products aren’t initally well received
by the public because consumers aren’t convinced
that that’s what they want. The iPhone X
for example was memed as the $1000 emoji
machine. And the Airpods were scoffed at as
overpriced bluetooth headphones. But over time,
both of these have become extremely popular.
In fact, the entire world is moving towards
iOS and Android is bleeding market share. This
is especially true in developing countries like
India. As soon as people are able to afford an
iPhone, they get an iPhone. And I’m not saying
this hype up Apple or anything. Rather, I’m trying
to illustrate how people don’t exactly do what
they say. If you ask anyone, they’ll say what they
want is a reasonably priced reliable smartphone.
But where they actually end up spending their
money is an overpriced phone that fulfills
intangible values such as status, aspirations,
fitting in, and whatever else. The bottomline
is that the Google Pixel is a manifestation of
what people say they want, not what they really
want and that’s why Google has struggled to ever
grow past just a niche market. With historically
high interest rates, the appeal bills and bonds is
the higher than ever, yet traditional brokerages
haven’t really adapted with the times. They
still expect people to use clunky bond tables,
scroll through long overwhleming lists, and even
use virtual keyboards till recently. And that’s
why we created our own modern bond platform: Silo.
At Silo, we prioritize the user experience and the
ease of finding and investing in the issuers you
know and trust, so that you too can lock in high
yields. Also, choosing a strong user experience
doesn’t mean sacrificing on safety. Every Silo
account is insured by $500,000 in SIPC insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance. Also, all
funds deposited on the platform will be maintained
by our trusted custodian, Interactive Brokers,
who has experience managing $373 billion worth of
assets over the past 45 years. It seems that this
is the case not just for the Pixel but Android
in general. Check out this video to learn more.